what is peyton manning going to do next
we have been asking that question since
he retired more than four years ago it
seems like every year someone tries to
hire him to become a broadcaster that is
something he has resisted the one thing
that he wants to do is eventually
run a team
and
he doesn't just want to run a team he
wants to own a team i don't think he's
ever chris going to have
the money necessary to be the majority
owner of a team but i could see him
being the guy who is the name the face
the voice while the person who actually
has the money and who holds the majority
of the equity is kind of hiding behind
the curtain and letting peyton manning
run the show but he'll have to have a
piece of the equity in order to do it he
recently spoke with bleacher report
about the fact that that that he has
already received offers to run teams he
said he's never had a formal contract
offer nothing in writing well that's
baloney it's never reduced to writing
until you know it's done no one's going
to reduce it to writing unless he says i
want to do it all that stuff happens
verbally and you come to an
understanding as to what's going to
happen and then once everyone says all
right we want to do this have the
lawyers draw up the papers so that's a
little he's playing a little fast and
loose with reality there it's clear he's
had some discussions but the bottom line
is he's going to want to be a
significant owner of any team that he
ultimately runs and i fully support it
whenever he does it he's gonna be
incredibly successful chris we've seen
others who have tried and have failed
uh
he will put in everything he has to he
and i think that's one of the reasons
why he hasn't done it and and there's
still a chance he never does it because
once he gets back in he can't do
anything halfway he is going to take
over he is going to make it an everyday
obsession and i think at this point in
his life
it may not be the right time for him to
do that
well i think that's fair i think that's
exactly what it is it's just not the
right time but i think it's only a
matter of time i do i i think at some
point hey listen there's only so much
golf and so many beers you can drink
until a guy like peyton manning's like
okay this is boring all right yep i know
you know i'm on the golf course and
having fun and maybe gambling with some
buddies but okay i've gotten my rush and
my life fulfillment out of that he's
gonna miss the energy at some point and
the daily challenges of the nfl i think
he's made for it first just two
knowledge too knowledgeable too smart
been around too many good players
understands team building you know got
to see a guy that's very similar to him
in the hierarchy of quarterbacks and
john elway do it who i think is a
phenomenal gm you know we've seen john
lynch of course who's having great
success with the 49ers i think it's only
a matter of time and who and when and i
always look at you know the tennessee
titans who have a little bit of an
interesting ownership you know
uh issue there right now and he played
in tennessee at the university of
tennessee so that makes sense and the
saints those are two where i look at do
i just go with if there's ever an
inkling for somebody to squeeze in there
i think it'll be peyton manning and to
me the big question is mike
does like peyton and eli go in it
together and pull their money together
to get some like you're saying some
equity of the team because they're gonna
need some other people or is this this
one of these kind of adventures that
peyton is going to be like no i'm doing
this myself eli you find your own team
if you want to do this i i want to do
this
i'm just that's where i'm very
interested in it
one of the realities of nfl team
ownership is as the team values keep
going up and up and up it is harder to
find people with the money who can
afford to own the team and also to run
the team and look there has been some
flexibility only the league does
whatever it wants to do and you can put
family money together and make it work
they could get archie and peyton
and eli and slap it all together but you
still have to have enough money to run
the thing too it is not an inexpensive
proposition and the other thing too is
chris you know this isn't like placing
him on a team to play for
because ultimately the owners of the
teams if the geographic location makes
sense fine but the owners have to want
to be able to sell yeah or carve off a
chunk of the equity and sell it to
peyton manning and uh until that happens
you know you may just have to sit and
wait for someone else to say i want to
sell and it may be a team that has no
connection whatsoever to peyton manning
i want to push back on one thing you
said too you said john always been a
phenomenal gm is phenomenal a little
over the top would you is phenomenal
really a fair assessment is that an
accurate assessment phenomena i only
know i only know two other gm's who went
to more than one super bowl in the last
decade you know and yeah he won one of
them he lost one of them and i know the
last three years haven't been good but
the first seven years of the decade were
very good and very relevant and he
brought in a lot of big time free agents
and a lot of good traffic so yes i do
and i think he set himself up john elway
and phenomenal is
and another run here
so i know it's not been perfect but i
still think it's towards the top of
football when you talk about a guy who
makes aggressive moves goes all in
and made his team relevant for a period
of time whether it was peyton manning a
keep to lead demarcus ware tj ward
emmanuel sanders i mean john elway went
through a five or six year period where
he pushed the chips into the middle of
the pot every year and went we're trying
to win the super bowl and yeah they lost
their way a little bit the last few
years but i think they're building a
resurgence there in denver right now
i think without peyton manning they
don't get to the super bowl well mike i
mean you know i think i think i think i
think i think i mean yeah i know it how
about this i know it i can say great
certainty
that without peyton manning and i'm not
taking away look he's the one that
landed oh manning he was able to land
him i'm not look at that in and of
itself was a tremendous accomplishment
everybody wanted him except the texans
the one team that peyton manning wanted
that didn't want him the rest of the
league wanted him almost and john elway
was able to get him so you got to give
him credit for that i give him credit
for that i just think phenomenal but
when when we look at the last three
years phenomenal may be a little bit of
an overstatement okay that's fine you're
right i hear you i hear you know what i
i get i overdo it because i hear
sometimes too many people being critical
of elway and i just think people have
forgotten about you know 2010 through
2016
where he was really awesome i think it
was 2011 through 2016 when he took over
the team
here's the one point i'll make and i've
kind of bounced all over the place on
this when they hired john elway in 2011
i said there's no other team that would
hire john elway than the broncos and
that in and of itself has to give you
concern about whether or not he's suited
for this job because no one else would
hire him for that job peyton manning
multiple teams would consider him to
come in and give him the keys but elway
has done a great job in his time running
the broncos football operation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports